DAMS, OPEN BORDER AGENDA
EXPOSED.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE THE 2020
DEMOCRATS ASSURED US THAT THEY
DON'T ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE
RADICAL AGENDA OF OPEN BORDERS?
>> OPEN BORDERS AS A RIGHT WAY
TALKING POINT.
IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
>> NO, I DON'T SUPPORT OPEN
BORDERS.
WE DO HAVE PROBLEM WITH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE NATION SHOULD HAVE BORDERS
AND BE RESPECTED.
>> OPEN BORDERS.
>> Laura: JUST LIKE HOW THEY
ARE NOT SOCIALISTS,
ANTI-AMERICAN OR
ANTI-LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ARE NOT FOR OPEN BORDERS.
YOU ARE THE CRAZY PEOPLE FOR
THINKING THAT.
THEY TOLD US ALL WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE.
BUT NOW THE DEMOCRAT LIES LAY
BARE.
ANNOUNCING A NEW ROLE ON FAMILY
DETENTION, KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
DRAWING OUT THE 2020 DEMOCRATS
TRUE RADICAL NATURE.
BRILLIANT.
THE NEW RULE AND THE
LONG-STANDING AND ABSURD CATCH
AND RELEASE APPROACH THAT
BASICALLY LETS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WITH CHILDREN
DISAPPEAR INTO THE COUNTRY'S
INFERIOR AND ULTIMATELY AVOID
EVER HAVING TO GO BEFORE AN
IMMIGRATION JUDGE.
NOW, FAMILIES UNDER THIS NEW
RULE WILL BE HELD TOGETHER.
AN IMPROVISED HOUSING WHILE THEY
AWAIT THEIR DAY IN COURT.
IN CHILDREN, OF COURSE, AT THE
TIME WILL BE PROTECTED FROM
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
>> SO PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD
SEPARATION.
I'M THE ONE THAT BROUGHT THEM
TOGETHER.
THIS NEW RULE WILL DO EVEN MORE
TO BRING THEM TOGETHER.
BUT IT WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA THAT
HAVE THE SEPARATION.
VERY MUCH I HAVE THE CHILDREN ON
MY MIND.
IT BOTHERS ME VERY GREATLY.
>> Laura: REACTING TO THIS
LIKE MOTHS TO A FLAME, THE
DEMOCRATS COULD NOT HELP BUT
REVEAL THE OPEN BORDERS FANATICS
THAT THEY TRULY ARE.
>> INSTEAD OF WORKING TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER AND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS, FOR
INSTANCE, TO BIND FAMILY MEMBERS
AND USUALLY THEY HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THE UNITED STATES.
TO FIND THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS
QUICKLY OR A SPONSOR TO TAKE
THEM INTO A LOVING HOME.
>> Laura: OKAY, THERE THEY GO
AGAIN, CASTRO IS EXPOSED RIGHT
THERE.
FIRST THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
NEW RULE IN CASE HE ACTUALLY
CAN'T HEAR, WILL KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
THAT IS WHAT CASTRO WAS SO
WORRIED ABOUT BEFORE.
ONCE THIS ACTUALLY ESTABLISHED
THEY ARE RELATED.
NOW, AN ANCHOR THAT ACTUALLY
CARED ABOUT THE FACTS WOULD HAVE
BEEN EJECTED THERE.
PLUS JULIAN CASTRO REVEAL THE
TRUE AGENDA ALL ALONG.
A MASSIVE RESALE OF MIGRANTS
MOST OF WHOM HAVE NO VALID CLAIM
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
REMEMBER, THIS COST YOU MORE
MONEY IN THE CROWDED IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND FACILITATE USE OF
CHILDREN TO GAIN THE SYSTEM.
UNLESS YOU THINK THE MAJORITY OF
THESE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS ARE
TODDLERS, HERE IS THE ACTUAL
FACTUAL BREAKDOWN FROM HAF.
72% OF THOSE MINERS WERE BETWEEN
THE AGES OF 15 AND 17 YEARS OLD.
AND ALL TOLD, 84% WERE TEENAGERS
FROM THE AGE OF 13 TO 17 YEARS
OLD, 18 TO BECOME ADULTS.
NOW, DEMOCRATS, LIKE CASTRO,
THEY LOVE ALSO TO TALK ABOUT
ALTERNATIVES, DETENTION.
IT IS BECOMING CATCHY ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
SO ALTERNATIVES, I WILL
TRANSLATE THAT FOR YOU.
RELEASE ALL BORDER PROCESSORS,
EVEN IF YOU ARE RELEASING THEM
INTO THE CUSTODY OF OTHER
ILLEGALS.
THAT HAS ALLOWED BY THE LAW.
AND IF THEY DON'T SHOW UP FOR
THE IMMIGRATION HEARING, NO
PENALTY, NO DEPORTATION.
THEY WILL NOT DEPORT THEM.
NOW, THE DEMOCRATS TEDIOUS
REFRAIN, LET'S GET TO THAT ABOUT
KIDS IN CAGES, IMMIGRANTS
DRINKING FROM TOILETS, AND
BABIES RIPPED FROM "LACTATING
MOTHERS" TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE,
LIBERAL MEDIA PROPAGANDA.
FAKE NEWS.
TRUMPS NEW RULE AND THE 1997
FLORA'S AGREEMENT WILL NOT ONLY
DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION A
DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION D
ASYLUM CLAIMS BUT IT WILL
ACTUALLY REDUCE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND SAVE LIVES,
INCLUDING THE LIVES OF ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
CLAIMED THEY CARE ABOUT, MIGRANT
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
BUT WE WERE THINKING ABOUT THIS
TODAY COME ALL TALKING ABOUT
DOING THE SEGMENT.
AND SADLY, THOSE CHILDREN ARE
JUST COLLATERAL DAMAGE TO THE
RADICAL LEFT.
AND SO ARE THE AMERICANS MAIMED
OR KILLED BY OPEN BORDERS
POLICIES AND STATES AND CITIES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
JUST MILES FROM HERE, EIGHT,
9 MILES FROM OFFICIALS IN
MONTGOMERY COMPANY, MARYLAND
DECLARED SANCTUARY STATUS AND
REFUSED FUTURE COOPERATION WITH
ICE.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BUT THE
MOVE OF COURSE AND THE DO-GOODER
JOURNALIST, THEY WILL NOT
CONNECT THE DOTS.
THEY WILL NOT CONNECT THE DOTS
NOT WHEN FOUR ILLEGALS IN THE
SAME COUNTY WERE ARRESTED ON
CHARGES IN THE LAST MONTH.
AND THE ACCUSED 26-YEAR-OLD
HUNTER ALLEGEDLY FOLLOWED A
WOMAN TO HER CAR, THREW HER TO
THE GROUND, STRANGLED HER AND
THEN RAPE AND LEFT HER FOR DEAD.
SHE NEARLY DIED.
WILL ANY MAINSTREAM MEDIA AS
2020 DEMOCRATS ABOUT THESE
ALLEGED CRIMES?
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT THE KIDS IN
CAGES AND OTHER CONCERNS AT THE
BORDER, BUT WHAT ABOUT AMERICAN
AND IMMIGRANTS IN THE
UNITED STATES BEING BRUTALIZED?
IT'S NOT GOING TO COVER IT.
IF YOU WEEKS AGO, THEY TRIPPED
OVER THEMSELVES EMOTIONALLY
MANIPULATING DISTRAUGHT
IMMIGRATION CHILDREN FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
HOW MANY TIMES DID THEY USE
THESE CHILDREN ON ERROR?
A LOT BUT THE SUFFERING OF THE
WOMAN IN MARYLAND?
JUST NOT WORTH A MENTION.
MORE HUMAN CARNAGE, MORE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
ALL THE NECESSARY PRICE TO PAY
FOR THE UTOPIA OF A BORDERLESS
USA.
THE LEFT LIKE CLOCK OR WORK WILL
RUN TO THE ACTIVIST JUDGE AND NO
DOUBT CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COMMANDER, ECOLOGY MASQUERADE'S
IMPARTIAL FEDERAL JUDGE, WILL
REBUFF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
YET AGAIN WITH A NEW RULE.
AND FOR PAST RULINGS, AND HOW
OUT-OF-CONTROL THESE ROGUE
TYRANTS HAVE BECOME.
BUT REGARDLESS OF THE LEGAL
OUTCOME, THE PRESIDENT HERE I
THINK PREVAILS POLITICALLY.
HIS VISION FOR ORDERLY MERIT
BASED IMMIGRATION FOR MANAGING
THE BORDER RAISED HIS PRAGMATIC,
IT'S COMPASSIONATE AND IT